I'm very tired having COVID. Any suggestions to help me build back my COVID, my fatigue app?
Well, one thing that can be very good for post-COVID fatigue is the clear talks, okay,
pulling that out of there. The Lubble, Lubble, Lubble kindase in the nano kindase can be very
helpful for that. Increasing blood circulation with a product like that and garlic and things like
that can be very helpful. Oxaloacetate has been found to be extremely helpful for post-COVID fatigue.
Oxaloacetate is a solid product called Betagene and a product called Oxaloacetate CFS for
Chronic Fatigue Syndrome. So, you try the much lesser Thor misphoric dosage called Betagene
first, much less expensive too. And I would give that a shot. We've had some people with really good
results with that. Matter of fact, this Oxaloacetate, I actually do an interview with, okay,
I remember that gentleman who owns that company did an interview, but a year ago with him,
I've been using Betagene since it first came out years and years ago. It has been proven to decrease
tumors. We have a number of our patients on Betagene, Slash Oxaloacetate for that.
We're really good for bringing tumors. First came out with a study with
Astrocytoma and glioblastoma. And then it now has been proven with breast cancer and other cancers too.